ja das lernen der zukunft heute ist es
ja noch so rein den klassenraum und
schon muss man das handy abgeben
tja in der zukunft wird es
wahrscheinlich anders aussehen
künstliche intelligenz wird die klassen
sind wir übernehmen und maschinen werden
in den schulalltag integriert vieles
läuft über das internet zum beispiel die
hausaufgaben dafür wird die schulpflicht
und das sitzenbleiben abgeschafft aber
ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle
wichtigen facts zum thema wie sieht der
schulalltag wohl in 50 und wie sie der
in 100 jahren aus jetzt im pixum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
kinder werden dann wohl schon sehr früh
gefördert es gibt hauptsächlich private
kitas und schulen
die träger sind nicht mehr die städte
und kommunen sondern bildungs der lage
oder medienunternehmen die eltern
bekommen ein großes mitspracherecht die
lehrerinnen und lehrer haben dagegen
kaum noch etwas zu sagen ihre rolle wird
sich wohl schon in naher zukunft extrem
wandeln den forschungsteams weltweit
stellen immer wieder fest dass lehrer
und lehrerinnen schülern allein nicht
helfen könnten stattdessen werden sie zu
coaches also zu lernhilfen die
individuell mit den schülerinnen und
schülern die nächsten lernziele
besprechen und ein zeitlimit dafür
ansätzen anders als sollte werden sie
wohl nicht mehr verbeamtet sondern
bekommen zeitverträge obwohl das hat ja
schon angefangen zudem haben sie die
pflicht sich regelmäßig weiterzubilden
das finde ich auch eine ziemlich gute
sache zusätzlich zum lehrerkollegium
wird es wohl mentoren geben also
ehemalige schülerinnen und schüler und
bekannte oder verwandte die die kinder
beim lernen unterstützen sitzenbleiben
gibt es nicht mehr
genauso wenig wie die noten von 1 bis 6
auch die schulgebäude ändern sich
grundlegend zumindest von innen es gibt
keine einzelnen klassenräume mehr
sondern große lernlandschaften die
schall wende in einzelnen bereichen und
dateien mittendrin unzählige computer
laptops tablets und so weiter und so
fort die kinder lernen in
altersgemischten gruppen vor allem aber
auch in arbeitsgruppen über das internet
im netz trifft man sich mit anderen
schülerinnen und schülern weltweit und
betrifft beispielsweise mit mit
schülerinnen und schülern aus japan die
ansätze des buddhistischen glaubens wie
gesagt die freie wirtschaft wird sich
auch in der schullandschaft durchsetzen
die eltern sind es jetzt die die
entscheidungen treffen welche schule
bitte die themen an die für mein kind
besonders spannend sind die eltern sind
es auch die bildungspaket buchen und
aufstocken manche forschungsteams sind
der überzeugung dass es in 50 jahren
eine art standard bildungsangebot geben
wird er quasi wie eine pflicht
krankenkasse falls die eltern und
schüler mehr wollen kann gegen geld
aufgestockt werden und beispielsweise
eine bildungsreise nach china gebucht
werden
ein teil kann beispielsweise auch über
bildungsgut
einer oder stipendien finanziert werden
und weil die staatliche hand raus ist
ist auch die schulpflicht längst
abgeschafft die eltern und schüler
können selbst entscheiden ob sie zur
schule gehen oder die neuesten
erkenntnisse aus der neurobiologie
lieber von zu hause aus lernen bestimmt
wird dafür so etwas wie eine art
unterrichtspflicht geben so dass die
lernziele zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
x von staatlicher seite abgefragt werden
die schulen haben bis spät abends
geöffnet und sind so wie heute auch vor
allem ein sozialer treffpunkt zudem gibt
es wohl von wissenschaftlicher sicht aus
die möglichkeit seine eigenen denkt
fähigkeiten testen zu lassen bin ich
eher der optische oder eher der
akustische typ daraufhin ausgerichtet
können dann die lerninhalte vermittelt
werden und das wohl bis zu zehnmal
schneller als heute
in weiteren 50 jahren also von jetzt an
aus in 100 jahren gesehen wird der
schulalltag noch einmal ganz anders
aussehen einige bildungs forschungs
experten gehen davon aus dass dann
künstliche intelligenz das lehrern
übernommen haben wird und ja das kann
ich mir persönlich sehr gut vorstellen
und zwar nicht nur im bereich der schule
die wissenschaftler um rosa kinn von der
londons global university geht
allerdings davon aus dass intelligente
computer die lehrer an sich nicht zu
hundert prozent setzen sie aber sehr gut
unterstützen könnten kopfrechnen und so
weiter gehört dann wohl sehr
wahrscheinlich auch der vergangenheit an
denn die gesellschaft hat wohl
spätestens in 100 jahren folgendes
erkannt die menschen sollten sich auf
das konzentrieren was sie wirklich
können den rest übernehmen computer ich
finde das sind hammer perspektiven wenn
er als erster erfahren wollte man das
alles realität wird dann meldet euch
hierbei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor
allen andern von mir vom neuesten video
eben vorab garantiert ihr könnt dort
direkt in der redaktion von klicks und
mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen
oder über abstimmungen mitbestimmen
einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich
nicht das aber mit der genau mit der
glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken die fünf besten
lernmethoden unbedingt ansehen ansonsten
würde ich mal sagen bis dann bleibt dran